Happiness is obviously something of great importance to us especially at this time of the year.
When it comes to the question, "Are you happy?"',...
...it always takes me a few moments to answer.
I realize that happiness doesn't just reside in my head, like contentment,...
...but it pervades the entire body.
So, when I say I'm happy, this means that I'm mentally and physically happy,...
...and we shouldn't take it for granted that health is the key component of happiness.
True. How many people actually feel thankful about what they have or just the way they are?
We all should be happy about what we have.
Good physical and mental health,...
...a family, shelter, our country, food, and the list goes on and on.
Let me tell you something that you might already know.
There is a movie called, "The Pursuit of Happyness."
Here, the word "Happyness" with a "y" is not misspelled,...
...but it is intended to show that the true meaning of happiness is being happy.
The spelling of the word is not actually important.
I can guarantee you.
I think that there are some conditions that need to exist in order to be truly happy.
Like you said, "Basic needs such as a good, supportive family, country, a healthy body,"...
..."a place to live and things to eat,"...
..."knowing yourself, what you like, and what you are good at,...
...so you can set realistic goals in life."